[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est vous Anne Poiré
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes journaliste et
réalisatrice prix Albert Londres votre
dernier film réalisé pour France
Télévisions s'appelle
Ukraine chronique d'une guerre annoncée
un document dans lequel vous revenez sur
les 8 ans qui ont précédé l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie au mois de
février dernier 8 ans d'une guerre dans
le basse dans l'est de l'Ukraine entre
ukrainiens et séparatistes prorus dont
le conflit actuel n'est que en réalité
l'acte 2 on regarde quelques images et
on en parle juste après
[Musique]
les Occidentaux la France l'Allemagne et
les États-Unis ont tenté de régler la
guerre au dombases multipliant les
rencontres les formats négociations et
de veines formule d'accord
les puissances occidentales ont-elles
tout mises en œuvre pour éviter
l'invasion de l'Ukraine en février 2022
que cela dit-il de leur attitude face à
Vladimir Poutine pendant toutes ces
années
occidentaux au longtemps fondé leur
politique sur l'idée qu'on ne se fâche
pas avec la Russie
la dissuasion repose sur l'armement mais
surtout sur la volonté politique
Vladimir Poutine nous a jaugé et a
déclaré
qu'on ne lui faisait pas peur
[Musique]
voilà pour ces quelques images à poirer
de ce film chronique d'une guerre
annoncée on ne peut pas comprendre ce
qu'il se joue en Ukraine aujourd'hui si
on ne si on ne comprend pas ce qui s'est
joué autour du don-basse oui je pense
que c'était très important déjà nous
quand on a commencé ce film au moment où
Vladimir Poutine n'avait massé c'est
100000 hommes au printemps 2021 on s'est
voilà de revenir en arrière en fait pour
comprendre les racines du conflit et
aussi l'origine de notre attitude par
rapport à Vladimir Poutine l'une des
questions que vous posez dans ce film et
celle-ci est-ce que les Occidentaux ont
vraiment tout fait ou fait comme il
fallait pour éviter ce 24 février 2022
mais bien sûr c'est la question qui se
pose le don-basse le conflit au dommage
arrive dans un contexte où on est déjà
en phase de Vladimir Poutine la France
essaye de de faire quelque chose en
Syrie aux côtés des Américains face à
Vladimir Poutine ils sont déjà dans
cette négociation au moment où la crise
du Dombas arrive donc tout ça est dans
un géopolitique très complexes mais
effectivement c'est intéressant de se
repencher sur ces étapes et ses
renoncements ces changements aussi
puisque dans les démocraties notre force
c'est que nous changeons donc la
dimension Poutine a eu plusieurs
interlocuteurs et c'est intéressant de
se rendre compte que si au sein des
administrations il y a des points de vue
divergence au sein de l'administration
américaine il y a plusieurs lignes de
face à Vladimir Poutine donc c'est
important pour nous de revenir dans ces
détails et aussi d'opposer ça à la
réalité sur place en Ukraine et dans le
Dombasle on a filmé
des décembre de l'année dernière des
personnes qui ont vécu dans leur chair
pendant 8 ans se confient sur la ligne
de contact un ancienne ligne de contact
et ce qui est terrible c'est qu'on voit
à quel point ce conflit a déchiré les
fatigues famille à quel point c'est
intime en fait on s'est familles sont
aujourd'hui réconciliables c'est un fils
et une mère qui ne se parleront plus
jamais ce sont des filles qui ne veulent
plus parler à leur mère parce qu'elle
est passée côté ukrainien et que pour
elle elle a trahi et c'est ça qui est
abominable
ce qui parle de la guerre et ceux qui la
vivent dit à un moment indécivile
effectivement que vous avez rencontré on
y reviendra dans un instant ce que vous
racontez dans le film ce sont côté
diplomatique du côté de ceux qui parlent
de la guerre 8 ans de tentatives parce
que les tentatives il y en a eu avec des
formats Normandie des accords de
Minecraft qui n'ont jamais été appliqués
qui sont tous qui ont tous qui sont tous
devenus des échecs diplomatiques
d'ailleurs ni les Européens ni les
américains ni les Russes ne sont
épargnés dans ce documentaire en réalité
et les Ukrainiens sont très critiques à
l'égard des occidentaux sur deux choses
principalement vous le disiez avoir
accordé une certaine valeur à la parole
de Vladimir Poutine d'un côté et puis
leurs moments également sur la question
de l'armement oui bien sûr c'est
en fait on se rend compte que sous Obama
il a été question de d'armer les
ukrainiens et au sein de
l'administration américaine c'est
quelque chose qui a vraiment divisé il y
avait une ligne qui se qui était très
favorable à livrer César mais à
s'opposer très fortement à Vladimir
Poutine et une autre qui a eu gain de
cause et qui qui me disait en fait si on
arme les Ukrainiens si on choisit la la
si on pousse cette voie militaire
l'armée ukrainienne n'est pas en état de
résister et donc elle va perdre et donc
c'est pas l'intérêt de l'Ukraine de les
armées finalement ce à quoi les
ukrainiens et notamment pas l'eau qui
l'ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères d'une pas du tout ça aurait
tout changé si on avait eu ces armes à
cette époque-là et je crois que c'est
lui qui dit que le 24 février dernier
rend nul et non à venir non avenue toute
politique occidentale à la gare de
des Affaires étrangères qui est
effectivement très critique en fait qui
disent voilà tous les calculs toute
cette idée de de négocier avec Poutine
de lui parler en fait ça ça ne
fonctionne pas ça n'a pas fonctionné et
ce drame du 24 février on est la preuve
et dans votre documentaire on le voit
bien à quel point vous le disiez tout à
l'heure vous Vladimir Poutine et le seul
le seul pion de ce jeu d'échec qui ne
bouge pas depuis 8 ans les chefs d'État
autour de lui tournent on est passé de
Obama à Trump en galamark elle est
partie François Hollande également et
lui il restait là
François Hollande dit de lui qu'il
utilise le éponge comme un élément de
négociation est-ce que à l'issue de ce
film vous diriez qu'il y a eu une forme
de déni quoi sur la réalité du régime de
Vladimir Poutine de Denis collectif je
pense que oui peut-être qu'il y a eu un
déni ce qui est sûr c'est que Vladimir
Poutine et Hollande le rappelle dans le
film a eu gain de cause sur la série on
a tous et tous les diplomates ont les
ongles l'exemple syriens qui auraient pu
servir de leçon c'est à dire que
Vladimir Poutine a eu gain de cause
surtout tout le monde a essayé de
négocier avec lui sur la Syrie et tout
le monde a échoué et il a rejoué ça sur
le sur le Donbass et c'est vrai que
quand dans un autre documentaire on a
cette parole de de
Emmanuel Macron face à Vladimir Poutine
qui dit peut-être que on se rendra
compte qu'il ment mais en fait on sait
qu'il ment tout le monde tous les
diplomates le savent François Hollande
le rappelle Vladimir a menti tout le
long c'est sa façon de négocier donc
c'est une il faut faire avec est-ce que
vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui on
s'investissement à ce point les
occidentaux sur cette ligne de crête
compliquée qui est celle de l'aide à
l'Ukraine sans être
pouvoir être taxé de belligérant par
Moscou est-ce qu'ils essaient d'une
certaine façon de de réparer les erreurs
qu'ils ont commis c'est huit dernières
années mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit
ce soit possible après je crois que la
ligne est toujours compliquée la ligne
française est toujours très critiquée en
Ukraine cette ce dis cette idée qu'il
faut continuer à jardin de négociation
continuer à parler
ce que ce que rappelle plusieurs
intervenants c'est qu'en fait il y a pas
grand chose à négocier avec Vladimir
Poutine il vient la table de négociation
quand il souhaite arrêter les événements
militaires ou figer une situation mais
il n'a jamais souhaité négocier rien
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure quand
vous avez commencé ce film on est en
2021 avant que l'invasion commence même
si on sent les prémices de quelque chose
de plus grand qui se qui se prépare la
réalité c'est que la guerre dans le bon
bah c'est un conflit oublié je l'ai dit
certains alors qu'en réalité il y a eu
toutes ces dernières années des
affrontements votre intention première
c'est d'aller à la rencontre de ses
habitants dont qui disent qu'ils vivent
dans une espèce de zone grise où tout
est gris logiciel la terre c'est ça
l'intention oui l'idée c'était de
rappeler que ces grandes négociations
dont on est parti prenante depuis tout
de suite puisque la France c'est
impliqué dans le format Normandie aux
côtés des Allemands dès le départ dans
la négociation donc la France est
vraiment partie prenante de ces
négociations et que c'est négociations
se font
dans la au milieu de la vie des gens en
fait et que c'est ces milliers de
personnes qui n'ont pas pu fuir parce
que beaucoup de gens ont fuient ce
conflit à ce moment-là mais des milliers
de gens n'ont pas eu cette possibilité
parce qu'ils avaient nulle part où aller
parce que il y a une grande grande
précarité et qui voilà ne souhaitait pas
pour certains partir et donc c'est huit
années d'un conflit qui n'a jamais été
gelé il y a toujours eu des combats il y
a toujours eu des bombardements on
pourrait dire peut-être contrôler c'est
à dire que chacun à chaque les
belligérant savait jusqu'où il fallait
aller voilà ça me dégénérait pas mais ça
a toujours eu il y a toujours eu des
bombardements et oui c'était important
pour nous de rappeler la réalité
concrète pour pour de terrain de ces
civils qui ont subi ça depuis 8 ans et
subit ces grandes négociations autour
d'eux au-dessus de d'autant que ce on
parle pas non petit territoire c'est
extrêmement grand le donbasse voilà il
concentre les enjeux
qui étaient déjà là il y a 8 ans
d'ailleurs et qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
dans le conflit et notamment voilà sur
cette ligne de fracture quoi entre la
tentation
occidentale européenne et la la et la
pression la pression russe oui tout à
fait tout à fait il y a beaucoup de
choses qui se jouent autour du don-basse
autour de ces gens mais au cœur de ce
conflit pendant ces 8 années il y avait
toutes ces familles qui étaient
déchirées et qui souffrait
de ces combats et de cette chose qui
n'avançaient pas qui ne bougeait pas et
parmi ces civils que vous avez rencontré
en 2021 donc beaucoup d'entre eux ont
fui vers Kiev notamment et vous êtes
sans nouvelles certains d'entre eux
alors en fait on a tourné dans deux
villages ça va et au pitné les femmes
qui étaient azayais de chez vous sont
tout de suite partis c'est intéressant
parce que ces deux femmes qui ont connu
la DNR qui ont vécu pour ça pour l'une
d'entre elles enfin toutes les deux à
vrai dire ont vécu en DNR donc elle
savait exactement à quoi s'en tenir si
le village était prié elle elles ont
immédiatement choisies de partir pour
l'une elle a été détenue elle a été
violentée sous les yeux de son enfant
donc elle savait exactement ce qui
allait se passer elle tout de suite
partie aujourd'hui ce village est
complètement détruit il a été pris dans
l'avancée en fait qui est en train de se
passer près de barmouth donc
pousser des séparatistes donc
aujourd'hui ce village est a basculé au
pitney les deux familles qu'on a suivi
donc Nicolas il y a fui il a rejoint
Kiev sur mai et il se porte bien il a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à joindre sa
mère mais il y a une petite semaine il a
pu l'avoir au téléphone donc on sait que
Larissa est vivante elle est dans sa
cave elle est sous les bombes son fils
ne sait pas comment elle parvient à se
nourrir depuis toutes ces semaines mais
elle est vivante et Sacha et Olga
malheureusement nous n'avons pas de
nouvelles d'eux dans le lombasse
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qui a pu
être la ligne de front cette dernière
année est-ce que le rapport de force est
en train de changer
je pense que c'est très difficile à dire
c'est en tout cas ce qu'on voit près de
barmouth aujourd'hui et près de pitness
et que ça devient difficile
à la reconnu dimanche en disant qu'il y
avait voilà cette cette poussée autour
de barmouth après au nord et au sud
c'est tout à fait différent et ça moi je
peux pas voilà c'est très difficile de
prévenir il y a beaucoup de questions
qui se posent en ce moment sur cette
voilà il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont
attendues peut-être des une offensive
dans un sens une contre-offensive qui se
poursuivrait c'est très difficile de le
savoir qu'est-ce que c'est huit années
ces échecs diplomatiques cet acte 2 que
peut représenter cette invasion globale
de l'Ukraine par la Russie attention
c'est une question un million de dollars
mais peuvent permettre de penser quoi
sur sur l'avenir à la fois de ce pays en
tant que nation et sur les intentions de
la Russie vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine
globalement est-ce que ça permet de de
voir lueur d'espoir ou de rester
globalement assez pessimiste
je pense que le 24 nous a février nous a
appris à ne pas faire de prédiction on a
tous nous la première y compris sur la
ligne de front les personnes n'imaginent
n'est pas ce qu'elle allait se passer
les fixeurs avec qui on travaillait les
négociateurs que j'avais moi des gens de
l'OSCE que constamment au téléphone
personne n'imaginait coulait pas qu'on a
interviewés lui-même ne croyait pas les
américains ils nous a dit notamment même
le même après le 21 février quand
Vladimir Poutine a reconnu les
républiques séparatistes à ce moment-là
il n'a ça pour lui décrédibiliser la
parole américaine tu dis ils nous ont
pas annoncé ça donc ce qui nous annonce
pour l'invasion c'est pas vrai non plus
donc voilà il y a il y a la rationalité
qui pensait à dire que qui tendait à
dire que le petit n’allait pas envahir
et puis il y a le passage à l'acte et
donc ça je pense que ça nous apprend à
être extrêmement
précautionneux dans ce qu'on peut
avancer voilà et dans cette guerre ne
pas oublier que ce sont des gens qui la
vivent cette c'est une des une des
raisons et une des grandes qualités de
votre film
Ukraine chronique d'une guerre annoncée
qui est à revoir donc en replay jusqu'à
dimanche sur le site de France
Télévisions un documentaire amorak vous
avez co-écrit avec Emile Rabaté merci
infiniment d'être venu nous en parler ce
matin chronique d'une guerre annoncée
donc pour ce documentaire